it's taken countless hours of
negotiation
1706 pages of written legislation today
is a day for Builders and more than a
few rousing speeches from President Joe
Biden America manufacturing is back
folks but
managed to fund some 2 trillion dollars
worth of new policies I'm Charlotte
Howard and these are
these are transform America's economy
[Music]
really big problems that America faces
climate change
Rising competition with China
stagnant American economic growth they
see a need to jump start America's
economy and the way they seek to go
about doing that is creating a frenzy of
activity within America's borders in
using subsidies and government policy to
boost private investment the buying
Administration is hearkening back to an
earlier time in America's economic
history they have utilized its riches to
create great Industries but this new
wave of manufacturing isn't going to
look like some of the ones in Prior eras
thank you
these new laws include all kinds of
subsidies for domestic Manufacturing in
particular chip making and clean energy
equipment so you have huge announcements
from companies building chip factories
there are car makers that are investing
in electric vehicle factories and
Battery plants but even as America tries
to become less dependent on China Supply
chains remain Global it's really hard to
disentangle from Chinese Supply chains
the other issue is that it's easier to
promote green projects than it is to
build them and that takes me to my third
takeaway
for a long time conservationists sought
to protect nature by blocking big
harmful new developments now what needs
to happen is a surge in new building
there needs to be new wind farms new
solar Farms big new transmission lines
that Traverse the country and all of
that is quite challenging because it can
take a decade for a renewable project to
connect to a grid it can take years for
a transmission line to be authorized so
if America wants to meet its goals both
for the climate and for its economy it
needs to help move green projects
forward faster
thank you for watching if you want to
read more about the effect of Democrats
plan both within America and throughout
the world please click the link it will
take you to the briefing that I wrote
with my colleague Simon rabinovich and
please subscribe to read and see more
foreign